just felt very like magical and fantasy
and very like disney
grab your glass slippers camila cabello
is channeling her inner cinderella
a dream
for me it's a dream come true on sunday
director kay canyon shared a
behind-the-scenes photo with the singer
and idina menzel
while shooting for the disney classic
what made you want to say yes to that is
the director
and it's i don't know it's just like i
just surround myself with
good projects if i can and it's
something i i'm
it sort of encapsulates all the
different facets of who i am
as a performer and it's just exciting
and
one major plot twist was revealed i'll
be playing the evil stepmom
well things have changed since then the
director revealed there are no villains
in the movie
kay wrote reveling the time i have left
shooting with cinders camila cabello
and her not evil stepmother idina menzel
no no no
this will be camila's acting debut she
shared her excitement by reposting the
pic
writing i love this film so much i just
feel i feel super
grateful e.t confirmed in august that
production on cinderella was preparing
to safely resume filming in the uk
the film initially started shooting in
february but halted a month later due to
the coronavirus outbreak
also starring in the upcoming
live-action film billy porter
the actor spoke to et about playing the
iconic role of cinderella's fairy
godmother
i got one big scene i come and slay
blow the roof off the joint and then i
get to go home so
and you always remember that character
the fairy godmother
she dresses she dresses the girl for the
ball
darling so i get to be that it's amazing
i'm looking forward to it